hello the names right Roy and raw
they're small borned impression so my
real bond impression just [ __ ] with
you guys alright so james bond is led on
a trail to uncover a secret organization
named Spectre not spectra spectre before
watching this movie i read some reviews
and i honestly thought to myself this
movie is probably just misunderstood i
felt like this would be one of those
films that the masses had issues with
but I'd be there defending it ok first
off the opening scene like everyone
saying is fantastic it's a beautiful
tracking shot and if you don't know who
James Bond is it sets him up fairly
decently and then it's followed by this
intense action sequence that's truly
bond reminiscent as a matter of fact all
the action scenes are beautiful to watch
they're all wonderfully choreographed at
all well shot however my main issues
come in between the action scenes
personally I thought the execution of
this story was very weak it's a very
serious film very self-important but it
has the rather confusing tone the spawn
movie does that thing where bond goes
around the world but any time there was
a location switch it just felt like it
was out of a different movie it felt
like it was a different movie like every
20-30 minutes they so like there was a
lack of consistency like people are
really loving the cinematography of this
film I love the action sequences how
they're shot but I felt like overall
there was a lack of consistency with the
cinematography however those issues
might actually just be blamed on the
script is very expositional very
plot-driven dialogue with no real
emotional substance to it I just feel
like this film really like and style if
I like I really like and having a
personality and after great films like
Casino Royale and Skyfall it's a major
disappointment to see how they
practically can character and just threw
in plot points that had no real
emotional resonance with the subplot of
em and a do name see that was so boring
it's exactly the plot a Mission
Impossible rogue nation but a very
boring execution of it and I felt like
they really should have done something
to enhance
he finds his m see when Judi Dench was
em there was interesting dynamics they
hated each other but they loved each
other Judi Dench was kind of like a
tough mom on bond ray Fiennes is not
compelling to watch he's rather cliche
more importantly he doesn't have an
interesting relationship with bond at
all however I'll say they included q
more on this story and I'm like what
they did with him they got to give him
some field action this time around he
served a major purpose in completing
this mission I really like what they did
with him and I think the actor is really
fun to watch to see this film I was like
primarily bored I found myself wanting
to hurry up and get to the next action
scene because the drama was so dull in
my opinion about the bond girl I feel
like indifferent towards cuz a part of
me likes her likes what her performance
was but the way she was written and the
way they told her story I thought it was
just another boring plot I know it's a
bond foam but these Daniel Craig films
have a much more serious tone and there
is some really just cheesy moments that
i'm not sure if they were intentional or
not i know its bond tradition for
double-oh-seven to use his
double-oh-seven inside a vagina yes sex
with women look at two times it happens
in this film it's so out of place it's
so cheesy especially with the first sex
scene if you guys have seen it I think
bond comes across a little abusive and
manipulative in the first sex scene he
asked see when it comes to the cheese of
this film they tried paying homage to
classic bond but instead of making it
like can't be fun they toned it all down
made it much more serious so I found
myself going I'd rather watch a fun Bond
movie with all the elements they have in
this because when you make it serious
it's now just the cliche movie and
nothing really original in there like
doing homage is one thing but just
rehashing is a whole other story okay
but let me backtrack a little bit they
didn't completely can character I just
felt like there was no true character of
bond being infused until like the last
half hour of this film but at that point
we're in the finale so we need the big
action sequence as well so even the big
reveals that should have an emotional
effect on bond like a serious emotional
effect it honestly seem like it didn't
really bother I just got to complete my
mission like having exposition of a
character does not equal to straw
emotional drama of a character like I
said earlier this one just doesn't
really have personality there's no real
flair even in its comedic moments
especially with the dialogue it seems so
off like when they tried infusing humor
the film was so serious that no one was
laughing in the theater because it just
came across awkward and very forced
another major issue I have with this
film is the use of Christoph Waltz a lot
of people are saying this and I greatly
felt it too his character is totally
wasted they teased him in the early part
of act 2 then he doesn't show up to like
the last half hour of this film in this
film is two and a half hours I will
admit when he's on screen he's the most
interesting person to watch he's more
subtle than I expected him to be but I
really felt like we could have had some
awesome dynamics with him and Daniel
Craig and christoph waltz two great
actors man just put them in more scenes
together I felt like the writers were
like but in Skyfall Javier Bardem comes
in halfway through the film and then
they heavily focus on him it would be
like we're copying Skyfall if we did
that it honestly wouldn't have been a
problem if you infused the villain more
especially when Christoph Waltz he's a
two-time Academy Award winning actor the
villain I did like though was Dave
Bautista he was a brute force barely any
dialogue but he had a wonderful violent
introduction that immediately tells you
everything about this character and he
was like a perfect physical threat to
bond it was more than just his
appearance the body language the facial
expressions he had down made him really
threaten to these plot points they tried
making it feel more personal but it
really didn't feel personal and that
really comes down in one of my main
complaints which is bond himself I know
me a lot of people arguing me on this
but I wasn't a fan of the way bond was
portrayed in this film you can't have
three prior films that explore bond as a
human being then completely stop that
and then go back to a bond that we knew
before Casino Royale was ever released a
very two-dimensional bond some people
still think Daniel Craig was great in
this role and he is but inspector I felt
like he looked tired he looked like you
was bored of playing bond I heard about
this interview after I watched the movie
where Danny
craig was pretty much saying he's sick
of playing bond and it really shows he
just seemed like he was over this but
then again that could be because of the
lazy script cuz the script doesn't
really offer moments for James Bond to
shine as a character see we could see no
Roy Allen Skyfall there was a great
blend of action adventure mystery would
just enough character for a Bond film
enough for it to really hit so you
actually care about bond and this he's
two-dimensional and like i said earlier
by the time we get to the moments where
we could get some character exploration
of the guy finally we're in the finale
so we don't have time to explore it so
the major question is this as bad as
quantum of solace my answer no it's not
is it more disappointing yes because you
got the same people who did Skyfall you
think this would at least just be
entertaining like I said action
sequences entertaining all the other
stuff really boring because you see what
quantum solace you'd be more forgiving
because they had like the writers strike
going on and then daniel craig and marc
forster practically had to write the
script themselves so we can be more
forgiving on that this one can't be as
forgiving on that's why it's a bigger
disappointment so yes action a solid d
Bautista is great I know I didn't talk
about her but Moneypenny I thought was
really good in the film to the minimal
screen time of Christoph Waltz is good
but overall this film had a very lazy
script there was no personality drama
was not interesting I was just overall
bored when action was not going on well
anyway guys thanks for tuning into my
upbeat positive review of Spectre I
guess it's a reading time um man I
should have established a rating system
I give it two out of five pubic hairs
one I have five pubic hairs as in five
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject
about by clicking this button up here
follow us on our social networks because
if we get enough followers week and yet
even more product placement on multiple
platforms I've been told by my
representation to promote my Instagram
and Vine more so follow me there and
maybe just maybe i'll post more but it's
really about the followers private
placement people
product placement